[Music]
very special edition of every damn day
we are playing a brand new game called
pile of money verse expensive food and
today we've got a 100 dollar pile of
single pills versus a 100 dollar grilled
cheese sandwich from a fancy restaurant
in New York City's financial district
this is how the game's gonna work in a
moment we're gonna have a few minutes to
discuss which we think we're gonna
choose and then they will be split
evenly so if two people choose the money
they split the money the three other
people would get the sandwich they are
not allowed to share do you guys think
you know how you're gonna vote no yes
all right let's move our sandwich Julian
[Applause]
Gold Lea house-cured bacon slow roasted
for 18 hours sharp max and let t-boz
which are two very expensive Swiss
cheese caramelized onions
homemade fig mustard shaved black
truffles you guys see the gold oh my god
okay boom so that looks very good and we
have a video to show the actual process
of making it okay so this is tweeted by
Business Insider so you know those guys
know about money and stuff this is a
$100 grilled cheese you can see the very
expensive cheese melted together two
different time take a look at that fig
jam today in house 18 hours of bacon
savings and that big mustard but at a
certain point you are going to write
your actual choice onto this board you
cannot show anyone else what you've
written that must remain secret
we will then survivor style go out and
show the camera what you voted for will
reveal everything and whatever you voted
for will then split it up so we're
either there's a scenario where if five
people choose the money we were
splitting it five ways and then we have
to destroy the sandwich and if five
people to the sandwich were sitting with
splitting the sandwich five ways and
then we have to destroy the money that
sandwich
are we ready to begin the debate so
that's kinda like those games you play
with your friends like werewolf or mafia
where we're all gonna lie to each other
now start that clock the debate begins
what do people think when are you ever
gonna buy yourself a hundred-dollar
sandwich like never this is the only
opportunity you're gonna be like rolled
foil and entropolis
right but also he might be doing this so
that we say he wants the money but
actually he's gonna take the sandwich it
could be a very layered cuz it's so
obvious that he wants the money by
saying that that maybe he does want us
to think he's gonna do honestly this
time chair they act like it's not going
this is the only time we're giving his
dad
you don't want to read a B but if this
is split you wouldn't be able to afford
this sandwich get the money but it's
true I can take which we save up and get
the semi but you're not gonna do so take
the lunch money my wife guys I think
believe in yourselves believe that you
can make $20 like we can make $20 just
sittin sort and you're saying that
experiences are more important exactly
okay well I think this is it reminds me
of the periphery the lab where basically
if you can convince everyone else to go
one way and then you go the other if
there's a scenario where four people
pick sandwich and you put the money
that's when you benefit the most right
or vice versa where you gonna eat that
bowls and I really think it's gonna end
up being three two things we need three
two yes I think either way we're like no
one's gonna come out on top this is an
all-or-nothing thing you will consume it
on camera
we're not playing nice here we're not
sharing it with people who are we're not
sharing Brian
[Laughter]
he's not part of that's so torn because
I'm like okay if everyone chooses money
then I that would be done can I do it
just sounds can I just do some
computations on my please if everyone
takes a sandwich I want to be pissed if
Jordan gets that money right
it's gonna feel really good if you walk
out of here with $100 it's gonna feel
really good you're the only person to
eat that sandwich everything else might
feel because if you cou if you walk out
of here with $100 you can go to
Delmonico's and eat the sandwich oh okay
can I talk to you what I think
everyone's gonna do yep okay so from
what I know about everyone okay I think
Jordan as much as he's doing whatever
he's doing deep down he's all about
experience he's gonna take the sandwich
yes okay Chris for sure is gonna take
the money okay Nate is a wild card like
me okay I really feel like we are
closest in opinion so I'm just gonna
whatever I do I think and Hannah I think
ultimately she's gonna go for the money
so that gives me two money one sandwich
and I think N squared which is amazing
we'll also be sandwich which means three
sandwich which means I'm taking them
[Applause]
okay do not show anyone what you to cast
your ballot couch people do not let
people see what you vote everyone you
must cast your vote okay I wrote an X it
could do a dollar sign it could be a
sandwich I'm not sure what is that's
gonna become okay so everyone has voted
Jordan you're up first
do not let anyone else see show the
camera and picture like survivor music
happening like it's very intense right
now
Hannah you're at the show the camera ah
hey hey dammit - Ryan Hannah - Ryan no
one look no one look Natasha Europe just
show but knowing law knowing listen
don't watch don't watch
the time for alliances has passed so
excited - like this money on fire oh
it's just eating ass am a gold foil tell
us why you like money on fire dude I
voted for sandwich I voted for that
money baby
give me that Jetta I voted for the money
as I said
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we are at the core who we say well I
should have known that handle would do
money buy your sandwich I thought you
were convinced I got I got a little gold
on my fingers should I should I put it
in my mouth so I put gold in my mouth
yeah maybe I'll give you the fries no
your fries though ok so right now I'm
gonna take a big-ass bite of some gold
[Music]
it's really like the bikes good and it
tastes so good just like rubbing in
their faces those poor idiots a few
children who need $33 this is the match
sharpie I believe it's pronounced which
is very good and expensive this is the
laser a cheese that believe it's called
also very good and expensive I'm being a
little facetious right now but truly
this is the best sandwich I've ever I
feel I feel pretty good about my choice
Jordan $5 for a bite just $5 you know
they have dogs that sniff out truffles
yeah it's pigs it's a $6 just a little
tiny bite I'll let you cut it off oh I'm
sorry
at this point it's become white in a
waste
[Laughter]
[Music]